alright I'm not going to spend a lot of
time on this and this is going to be the
one and only video on this matter it's
sort of a minor drama around a video we
did yesterday regarding the Seth rich
conspiracy theory I'm not going to
rehash the entire story nor spend a lot
of time on it because I realized very
quickly yesterday that most of my
audience understands and by and large
agrees with my view on the story that
despite the influx of trolls and haters
downloading our YouTube video which by
the way it doesn't hurt us at all it
people think they're going to show up
and down vote and it's really going to
be bad for us
it's just engagement according to the
YouTube algorithm but in any case that
aside most people in our audience also
don't know who any of the people in the
video clip I played are neither the arty
hosts nor a che Goodman or the others on
the panel so I'm doing this as a YouTube
only thing we're not putting it on our
TV radio or podcast show that audience
definitely doesn't care about this
beyond yesterday's segment so to set it
up we did a clip called arty Seth rich H
a goodman conspiracy theory implosion
okay a small part of this clip discussed
a guy who makes YouTube videos named H a
Goodman who we previously interviewed on
our program when he was during the
primary season convinced Bernie Sanders
was going to win even as the numbers
increasingly suggested Bernie wasn't
going to win it again I voted for Bernie
Sanders this was not my opinion this was
what the data pointed to at the time
anyway here's the portion of yesterday's
video that relates to H a Goodman which
is sort of the jumping off point and
again this clip is not about the Seth
Rich thing that is a whole other story
right this is about specifically the
drama that surfaced because of what we
said about a che Goodman and what I
later said on Twitter so let's start
with the portion of yesterday's clip
that relates to a che Goodman yesterday
on the David Pakman show reddit
discussion forum a video was posted of
an RT segment Russian state media
segment that aired this week where they
hosted a panel of three
people having a debate about the
conspiracy theory surroundings
Etheridge's death one of the people on
the panel was a che Goodman who was
enthusiastically supporting the
conspiracy theories now if that name
sounds familiar to you a che Goodman was
on our show in January of 2016 during
the election talking about an article he
wrote where he swore up and down that
Bernie Sanders would absolutely be the
next u.s. president no matter what I
think he continued to say that Bernie
would be the nominee if not the
president
up until the day Hillary Clinton closed
the nomination and I believe even later
than that sort of arguing that any day
now Hillary Clinton's going to be
indicted or something like that Bernie
will end up being the nominee and
ultimately the president so the guy in
the debate arguing in favor of the
conspiracy is once again a che Goodman
who has a career as a columnist
basically exclusively catering to the
Bernie or bust crowd that's a che
Goodman has become popular look at his
track record in terms of his YouTube
subscriptions I have no personal problem
with this guy I've interviewed him he's
offered to come back on the show which
we have not taken him up on he spent the
entire election vilifying Hillary
Clinton in saying she should be
prosecuted because of the email server
so completely as predicted we were
talking in the studio before we did this
segment this is going to trigger a chain
man and I would suspect that within
minutes of the video going up he and his
followers are going to be tweeting at us
about just how inaccurate everything is
this this also led to a twitter exchange
where a che Goodman also claimed that I
was lying on Twitter I tweeted needless
to say you said tons of nonsense Hillary
ready to endorse Bernie when she's
indicted when not if note that FBI
source says indictments coming blah blah
blah Nha Goodman responded yes if
Clinton was indicted Bernie would win
the presidency not just nomination never
said anything you claimed in your video
and of course this is not true and I
will just show you a little bit later on
in the video instances where he was
saying not if Hillary Clinton was
indicted when Hillary Clinton is
indicted that the indictments are coming
now just a couple of other quick things
before we get in here a che Goodman
again was so triggered by all this that
he started saying that I'm just making
stuff up and and there's a few tweets
floating around about how you know I I
got owned and I admitted to having made
up the quotes and it all relates to this
tweet where I said after being asked for
some quotes no idea off the top of my
head it was nonsense back then it's
irrelevant now this clip was only
tangentially about you and he sort of
took that to mean oh because I don't
remember the quotes right now I
fabricated the entire broader idea that
he was insisting Hillary's indictment
was coming any day and Bernie was going
to win no I literally met like in the
moment that he tweeted me at 427 p.m. on
May 31st 2017 I didn't have quotes from
him from six months prior in front of me
and then also another video with the
subject in all caps which I don't know
what the deal is would be all caps but
that that's maybe something for a
different day David Pakman thinks Seth
rich kim.com WikiLeaks evidence is
conspiracy theory my response I didn't
mention kim.com once in my entire video
I mean I genuinely have no idea what
what this is even about it all just
seems very very out there here's a bit
of that video if Democrats wanted the
super-delegates
before she stole the nomination should
have sided with Bernie if they wanted to
win and even after she won the
nomination there was still a chance that
had they stated you know Clinton can't
win especially after the Comey letter I
mean I never said he what that was going
to happen I said hey if you want to
insure Trump doesn't win find some way
to get Bernie back into the race and
again he's saying this is becoming very
semantically involved there's a chance I
said that Bernie would still become the
nominee not that it was going to happen
listen any of us could say that at any
point it doesn't make it a newsworthy or
noteworthy to say Hillary could be
indicted Trump could die Mike Pence
could
be the guy that's selected to take over
we're really digging into the weeds here
to deny what it was that that was said
so okay let's just go through a couple
things here again real quick and if you
don't care about this in you've already
you're about ready to click off the
video I don't blame you
the the clip really was about seth rich
but number one a che said that bernie
definitely would be the president the
nominee that hillary clinton was going
to be indicted this is a tweet from july
third again the the primaries were over
at that point it was over and a che
goodman put out a video which he tweeted
about called checkmate Hillary Clinton
needs President Obama's pardon after FBI
indictment Bernie wins again no
hypothetical there it's all just Hill
Clinton needs the pardon after FBI
indictment Bernie wins that was July 3rd
On June 10th and again the the primaries
all but over on June 10th I mean all
only Washington DC was left to vote on
June 10th and again a tweet very simple
focus on Clinton's special access
program intel on unencrypted email
server and no way around FBI criminal
indictment done D one:1 stand maybe if
15 different things line up blah blah
blah blah blah okay let's go now to just
a little bit of this video where he says
in no uncertain terms James Comey is
going to recommend indictment now this
relates to my tweet where I said that an
FBI source was saying that there would
be indictment I think he took it to mean
something like I'm saying he had a
personal source in the FBI or something
along those lines again it's a semantic
game if this is what you're pointing to
for my lack of credibility then consider
me not credible because he as you could
we'll see here he is saying the FBI is
going to indict Hillary Clinton only the
FBI
could be the start of whatever sequence
of source telephone that relates to
again not a personal source of a che
Goodman but he's talking about the FBI
is going to indict Hillary Clinton take
a look these sources have for months
been saying that Hillary Clinton is
going to go to Guantanamo so just wait
for James Comey the Honorable James
Comey to formally recommend indictments
because it's going to take place Hillary
Clinton has made an absolute mockery of
the American intelligence community so
Bernie supporters Bernie Sanders stay
patient the indictments are imminent so
he repeats these claims this claim about
the indictment is imminent over and over
and over again on multiple platforms it
never happened
and and I don't know you know what what
do I think
based on the down votes on our video I
think that this guy a che Goodman does
have some followers what do they think
about the fact that he was talking about
this for weeks as a done deal and it
just never happened let's go to another
video here and this relates to
continuing to say that Bernie Sanders
would be the nominee and/or the
president up until and even beyond when
Hillary Clinton had secured the
nomination here is a video clip where he
will say well listen for yourself here
the checkmate the political checkmate is
this Hillary Clinton knows that she's
going down the FBI is going to take her
down she knows this the unnamed sources
are trying desperately to spin and to
deceive like they always do these
unnamed sources have been saying it's a
security review it's not a criminal
investigation she's not the subject we
know all of that is baloney when the
indictments hit Hillary Clinton will not
concede for at least a week or week and
a half or two weeks and she'll try to
take it to the convention what will take
place is this eventually when Bernie
Sanders makes a strong passionate case
and he takes the gloves off and he says
this is my Democratic nomination my
opponent can serve jail time my opponent
is corrupt and my opponent is a liar he
has to go there
he has to go there but once the
Democratic nomination is Bernie's
Hillary Clinton needs after the
indictments Hillary Clinton needs
President Obama to pardon her none of it
happened again he said when the
indictments hit when the indictments hit
once the Democratic nomination is
Bernie's Hillary Clinton needs Bernie
Sanders to pardon her once the
Democratic nomination is Bernie's that's
not maybe once the Democratic nomination
is Bernie's once means when not if
never happened same video this video is
from the third of July this was exactly
as I said on my segment yesterday after
the Democratic primary was over all the
votes had been cast that Bernie Sanders
when Bernie Sanders secures the
Democratic nomination also from this
Bernie Sanders will become Democratic
nominee that's for sure
the indictments are imminent the reason
ties in to this segment there you go
Bernie Sanders will become the
Democratic nominee that's for sure wrong
the indictments are imminent also as you
probably know wrong just to flesh it out
a little bit more June 19 2016 8 again
after all the votes had been cast in the
presidential primaries thank you greatly
appreciated thank you so much and we
will win this Bernie is going to win
thanks again of course that didn't
happen June 29 2016 it was an excellent
piece although I believe Bernie will
still win the nomination States Hillary
Rodham Clinton can still lose and of
course nobody thought that that was
going to happen and again if his only
defense is this sort of semantic
linguistic defense that it could have
happened and his tweets were implicative
of that possibility if that's the
strongest case you can make then by all
means have at it Hoss so listen I
apologize for boring our core
audience with this I don't expect
anybody who has committed ideologically
to the idea that I am untrustworthy and
I made things up out of thin air most of
those folks they're pretty far in at
this point and they're not going to be
convinced but I've put together a
response and I think that at this point
I'm ready to consider the matter closed